rated M for Mature
all right kiddos I know you're all
excited to watch a new trailer and
whatnot but there's a lot of unanswered
questions about the chronological blah
blah blah about this game so let's just
get to it
story goes something like this
Borderlands which I wasn't in
Borderlands the pre-sequel which is
where my story starts and is currently
available for purchase followed by
Borderlands 2 and now hails from the
Baudelaire have we got it everyone good
can we start the freaking trailer
already you're going to be reporting to
me now Rhys I want you to know the
promotion that you work so hard to get
that's still coming to you that's why
I'm gonna make you assistant vice
janitor
can't let that prick get away with this
we still miss Dean
Vasquez set up a deal on Pandora for a
vault key one of us moves up we are
this latest scam was our biggest yet the
one that would set us up for life you're
the one that'll close the deal by
playing whatever role you need to this
place is a garbage land of sand and
sadness you came to Pandora now you get
to live like we do we got a couple
Hyperion warmongers gentlemen the bot
climate time clock in hard money
nutjobs what's we founded you can talk
about who gets what and how much we're
not bald hunters
really
did you think you could follow my
footsteps
you're you're really cool it is
I wanted you to know that
Oh